pop
[Musique]
samedi soir 21h à sa mort dans la région
parisienne
ici toutes les fins de semaine et jeunes
se retrouvent eux se posent
régulièrement la même question que
va-t-on faire ce soir
le café est le seul refuge après les 48
heures de bureau ou du sinn fein ont des
problèmes étant donné le nom de cornet
pour se réunir chez des camarades juste
en quoi pourquoi d'escrocs et pas chez
l'un d'entre vous jusqu'à quand
on voit beaucoup plus de monde et plus
souvent on a sans arrêt des contacts
avec les gens et ces mots s'intéressent
enfin surtout pour nous dans une affaire
de sortir vous avez un bol un programme
particulier ne saviez ce que
vous préparez votre à s'allier trois
mois dans l'abandon il arrive très
fréquemment coup
ici en l'occurrence nescafé
tout laisse à le mans est ensuite combat
au cours de la discussion qui propose
une certaine sortie par exemple une
balade enfants en pleine nuit
qu'est ce que vous allez faire mais pas
chez soi on n'a pas encore eu l'occasion
d'en parler ça fait convenir comment
êtes-vous reçu dans l'ensemble dans les
bistrots comment ça se passe franchement
cette année les cafés mais disons qu'en
général ces célèbres doortal achète de
vélo dans les mains pourquoi on vous
rend fou dans les bistrots s'il vous
arrive de chahuter ou prochainement
l'état ses nombreux alors en principe
dans l'ain peu court donc j'ai un
précieux
[Musique]
à 21h30 foyer des jeunes travailleurs à
créteil ici on temps d'organiser la
soirée du samedi mais on échappe
difficilement à l'ennui on a l'habitude
de partir en week-end
quand on veut ou en vous ce week end si
on est parti il ya deux semaines à
deauville ou bien sinon on essaye de
sortir dans les salles est fort aux
fortes tous les samedis soirs des
meilleurs au travail
on dit souvent que les jeunes s'ennuient
ennuyer votre histoire qu'est ce que le
foyer des jeunes travailleurs vous
proposent généralement comme activité
c'est ce moment il ya eu l'ouverture
d'un bar tous les samedis il ya une
espèce de fait
soit le plus soit ré
odense
samedi soir en banlieue c'est aussi la
ronde régulière des patrouilles de
police alors ce soir on s'en va faire
une patrouille vers nos gens vers le
bowling de genre alors on va voir
et particulièrement les jeunes et voir
un petit peu ce qu'ils fabriquent ce
soir 6
les gens qui n'ont pas de plus patient
faut voir aussi les gens avec les deux
mêmes seuils
- genre de drogue
et
original
qui n'a pas de place dans cet endroit
les gens qui viennent d'ailleurs et
particulièrement ceux qui vénèrent
groupe et entendre à essayer de
connaître leurs intentions
et
oui
[Musique]
dites la moto n'a pas toujours bonne
réputation il existe dit on des bandes
et qui terrorise un peu la banlieue
quand j'ai vraiment et ça l'est encore
est-ce que vous fréquentez les maisons
de jeunes maison de la culture générale
esprit indépendant est resté libre il
aime bien faire ce qu'ils veulent comme
la maison de
les autres cultures ou codes déjà l'état
c'est la défense des ae pas au cinéma
mais ça nous arrive est ce que vous êtes
souvent confrontés de samedi soir les
contrôles de police n'ont pas rarement
parce que ça c'est pas de nous je suis
parti généralement une c'est par moi
j'avoue que les gros jeux comme les
vérifications d'identité j'en ai eu deux
trois mais au même titre que les
automobilistes saison je trouve ça un
arrêt sur un pont ou alors sur une
avenue dans mon lieu en général
la police n'arrête le traitent
correctement quand on est en groupe
quand on est tout seul si on tombe dans
leurs ma on se mettra des djeun petit
con mais ça change quoi
[Applaudissements]
étais tu crées d'un restaurant tu t'en
ailles toi tu es au lycée quand tu
travailles
effacés
voilà ce faire il nous faut nous aussi
montré notre autorité parce que
l'autorité est à peu près que nous qui
pouvons la montre et maintenance avec
des parents alors bien souvent avaient
perdu leur autorité alors il n'aime pas
être un peu bousculée mais quelquefois
il faut le faire part au s'adresse à une
dizaine de jeunes en même temps si nous
nous imposons pas par une présence forte
nous n'obtiendrions bas les rangs des
rendements que nous avons actuellement
[Musique]
22 heures
un autre café dans le val de marne le
bistrot apparaît comme le lieu
privilégié de rencontres
mais si également celle attente attente
aux mails et d'ennui et de résignation
[Musique]
parce que le problème des loisirs se
pose la même façon pour les sites pour
les larmes aux services là je pense pas
parce que je suis plus attendre un coup
de fil disant tu viens au cinéma vient
dîner quelques fois les garçons le
skieur faire je trouve qu'une fille a
quitté les feux n'est donc le problème
est fan est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'il existe une forme de
sa négation racisme anti-jeune parle de
quelle façon vous ressentez ce racisme
anti-jeune on va du stress que tu
pouvais faire trois pas encore arrêtée
par actif parce que tu fais
[Musique]
22h30 thierry une partie de ses amis
motards ont choisi de faire une balade
de nuit
d'autres se sont décidés pour la
discothèque de la région mais les portes
ne s'ouvrent pas pour tout le monde
premier barrage le prix des
consommations pour de nombreux jeunes
accéder à la discothèque est une
promotion sociale
les jeunes viennent ici en voiture pour
la bonne raison c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
nez de clown ratio à moins de 4
kilomètres les prix des consommations
puisqu'il ya des jeunes qui sont
abordables tout en étant
relativement élevé samedi par exemple la
première tranche et les consommations si
on n'est pas un peu l'impression que
c'est un barrage pour les jeunes tous
les jeunes n'ont pas les moyens et les
consommations à prendre quand les jeunes
sortent
je m'entends les jeunes qui veulent
souhaiter d'être tranquille puisque
la cnr a buté pour les ouates pas calmé
très tranquille il n'y a jamais de
problème
c'est quelque chose qui se paient ya
deux ans les jeunes se prennent souvent
une sorte de racisme anti-jeune qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
s'il ya un racisme donc des jeunes
maison et surtout de leur faute à sarko
et
si on veut disons préserver quelque
chose de l'état budget c'est pas pour
moi ce n'est pas du racisme est obligée
de préserver il n'avait pas l'impression
vous pour un certain nombre de jeunes le
problème des loisirs est lié à un
problème d'argent
c'est obligatoire nous sommes dix après
19 heures une philanthropie qui étaient
créés sont automatiquement aux questions
d'argent ce qui vous arrive de refuser
des jeunes bien sûr mais pourquoi une
très grosse une très grosse préparation
d'ailleurs tous les ans fin de semaine
beaucoup quelle tenue exigée vous de vos
projets il en rêve tout simplement une
tenue correcte c'est à dire disons qu'on
a lille le buzz on le devine par exemple
23 heures la patrouille de nuit est
appelée pour une bagarre la salle des
fêtes d'alfortville
[Musique]
bon là on attend maintenant on a un
appel pour une bagarre dans un bar à
pince quand on y va tout de suite hein
alors il faut agir énergiquement parce
qu'on n'est pas nombreux et barrett la
bagarre est importante alors chauffeur
en vitesse
[Musique]
oh
23h15 les changes de coups de poing
n'aura duré que quelques minutes
[Applaudissements]
ça fait pas la paix des attaques étaient
des baptêmes de l'accueil c'est tout
je n'ai absolument rien vu je sais qu'il
ya une bagarre à chaud est intervenue et
on arrête le bal pour éviter d'avoir des
incidents beaucoup plus important cette
année réside un des organisateurs non je
me suis je saigne pas du tout je n'ai
pas pris un coup ça arrive souvent ici
c'est la première fois que je fais un
bal de la saison
qui sont les jeunes qui vendent ici les
jeunes qui viennent de toute la région
toute la région oui savais pas du tout
comment ça s'est passé absolue marty
d'où je sais pas
des bagarres dans les bals on ne sait
jamais vraiment comment et où elle
commence
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé alors ce soir
commissaire ici il s'est passé comme
malheureusement ça se fasse trop
fréquemment nous avons des bagarres à la
fin les balles
vous avez une clientèle qui vient pour
danser s'amuser et une autre clientèle
qui elle vit avec des intentions moins
pures et qui et espère trouver un
défoulement à la fin du bal en
échangeant quelques coups de poing et
tous les prétextes sont bons
quelquefois certains ont un peu bu et
d'autres sont énervés mais vous savez
c'est fréquent écédente malheureusement
dans tous les balles comme ça en ce
moment
attend il ya un truc qui veut voir si tu
veux c'est que faut replacer dans un
contexte général les mails par exemple
ils ont pas d'occasion se fait
s'exprimer au niveau de reboulleau haut
niveau dans famille et tout ça vous
amène dans les bals du samedi soir
qu'est ce qu'ils font généralement bombe
à un petit truc un petit incident ils
ont un peu trop bu se hisse libère ils
boivent bons pilotes n'importe quoi il
sera un peu tout le tout le système sud
éducation d'éducation à l'heure actuelle
peu qui fait pour les jeunes et leur
comparer ce pont pas justement leurs
besoins on a le droit de faire du ping
pong du maïs ou des moines de musique et
collection une collection de terre mais
tous par contre si tu est important de
faire des booms ta pouvoir faire des
boules parce que ça fait du bruit que
les conduit sa sécurité sont en jeu
repose respectable de jeunes faut croire
est-ce que vous fréquentez un peu la
maison des jeunes
il ya un fossé qui est creusé entre le
monde des jeunes travailleurs disons un
monde d'étudiants
et où le contact devient de plus en plus
difficile c'est pourquoi on ne fréquente
pas tellement la maison des jeunes tiens
vous proposer par exemple demain de
gérer un foyer ce serait bien vous étiez
entièrement responsable des fouilles
c'est à dire encore une sorte de 2g /
etc
dix ans ont l'expérience pourra
peut-être est enthousiasmante c'est
certain seulement ça pose des problèmes
surtout au niveau des individus parce
que gérer une foyer n'est quand même pas
gd chose qui est à la portée tout le
monde je crois c'est une opinion qui est
plus personnel mais qu'est ce que ça
veut dire aussi chaire une maison
entièrement la responsabilité d'une
maison de jeunes là il faut voir aussi
si les gars sont formés pour la gérer
c'est ça le problème
si tu remets sens le problème de
l'éducation si les mecs ils ont reçu
leur éducation à l'école dans la famille
même dans leur boulot qui leur
permettent si tu veux de bomba de
prendre en charge leurs loisirs et tous
et que bon bah si tu va redonner maison
de jeunes à l'heure actuelle qui met 50
go là dedans qui si on ferme rien faire
du tout parce qu'ils n'ont pas justement
capable d'organiser l'euro même leurs
loisirs
l organiser leur vie ce qui est normal
d'ailleurs dans le système dans lequel
on vit
ajouté aux policiers quel genre de délit
ou à venir constater le samedi soir et
le samedi soir c'est surtout des délits
mineurs
des idées justement tu es par les
mineurs et c'est en général des vols
pour faire une sortie balade samedi soir
les vols de mobylette photo est
également des vols d'accessoires
automobiles
évidemment le plus grosse affaire
puissions avoir le soir c'est des
grosses bagarres dans les bals 0 h 30
versailles palais des congrès ici la
ségrégation raciale et sans ambiguïté en
la fiche dans la pratique ouvertement au
rez-de-chaussée une salle exclusivement
fréquenté par des jeunes gens cravate et
au sous sol une autre salle réservée à
la clientèle nord africaine
organisées souvent des balles à
versailles à bersaillin principe des
balles au ventre ou samedi parfois le
dimanche en kabylie on dit que ça à
chaud souvent parfois certaines heures
la température puis le les clients qui
sont un peu nerveux où il ya des
irritations trois d'entre eux transférés
quel genre de client vient chez vous il
faut le dire c'est embêtant mais ce
qu'il veut en fait cacher des problèmes
[Musique]
c'est à cause de raciste égard ils nous
aiment pas non nous voudrons bien amusé
on est des jeunes comme moi tous pareils
comment ça se passe quand vous
comprendrez dans un bar dans une autre
quand on se présente dans un bal à côté
de la porte il faut fait une grave at et
puis des français qui rentrent comme ça
sans cravate dudit sonore coppens ses
développeurs et si tout ça et c'est
évident a déclaré l'état il faut il faut
fait une cravate pour rentrer pour nous
faut une cravate mais non il faut pas
dix graves à 30 comme ça non halal à 12
alors je vous dis pourquoi leur antre
n'en attends tu te la joues mal est
rentré fumer parce que c'est un homme
[Musique]
une banlieue à l'autre l'ennui le rejet
en jean de l'agressivité et la violence
devient la seule tentative de
communication noiseau le bal agents
layton exemple 24 25 ans oui oui un peu
de peinture c'est où sont les jeunes qui
désirent les jeunes bien sûr la valeur
faisais pas l'amour de samedi sera
maintenant c'est plus balle pourquoi pas
parce qu'on est plus jeune
c'est très fatigant le bal et c'est
quelqu'un de plus jeune encore des
d'affaires de son histoire employés que
compte faire le blog encore ne s'amuse
pas ici c'est encore assez dangereux
quand même de la préfecture ça il
recommande que tous soient lisses et ou
encore de bangor
[Musique]